it seems to me very likely to be an
overheated conspiracy theory it
certainly heated
I think it's overheated there's
certainly a rush to judgment you say
concerning senior politicians thirty
years ago it may concern senior
politicians thirty years ago it may not
there may be no senior politicians
involved in it at all all we know is the
Geoffrey Dickens who was a delightful
man we all like Geoffrey very much but
he he was pretty nuts in in life he had
his he had his theories he had lots of
conspiracy theories and he did believe
that Britain was in the grip of a huge
pedophile ring and it involved very
senior people in government and I think
it's highly unlikely that the Home
Office would simply have wilfully
destroyed or burnt the documents that he
gave to the then Home Secretary I don't
know I don't say that we shouldn't look
into it I just think everybody needs to
calm down a little bit I know it doesn't
feel like a rush to me I'm going to wait
to 20 years since I was aware of major
cover-ups and and people interfering
with my investigations when I was trying
to protect children and where
instructions came from for those
interferences I don't know so I want
some answers but so he knew about these
particular allegations I was
investigating many many allegations of
sexual sorts of children and murders of
children I was working with I was
working with the police we were
investigating suddenly the police were
taken off my investigates of the most
serious crimes you could imagine against
children multiple numbers of children
children were being taken all over the
country to be abused in different places
by different people you have a Germany
confidence a that an inquiry would would
put these matters to rest no but I can
ask some questions I waited 20 years
says I'm not going to stop trying to
find the answers to such incredibly
serious matters a lot of the people who
were involved are still around they're
still alive many of the people I was
looking at are still in senior positions
in children's services and so on
why do you think it is that we have to
wait 30 years and then have an inquiry
into these things
well more informations come to light now
through the internet where social media
obviously a lot more victims and
survivors have come forward than ever
before my inbox is full every day people
comes up to me with stories to tell all
these children who have been yeah as you
say if they have been taken to secret
locations to be abused by perhaps senior
people you'll presumably be able to find
some of the children too to testify to
this where you see a lot of the ones I
was working with in our adults yes or
yes they will of course cannot testify
but we need to have a lot of things in
case for that support systems witness
protection and an inquiry won't solve it
because it'll do so much it'll get us a
bit further but what we what I've argued
for for 20 years is a National Police
investigation team because we need
somewhere that we can take people can go
to that where they make the connections
across the country when I went to
Scotland out with my evidence by using
ttan i was then used both got me out to
go all over the country to liaise with
other investigations like north wales
and so on but nobody was connected
connecting it all up and so I was
hearing many names many many everyone's
pressing in after names though it's only
names but every single every place I
went to I was hearing names of all kinds
of people and nobody's ever joined those
dots up I won't ask you for names but
but I will ask you you do have names do
you in your own head and these are very
senior people and they are senior people
in the world of politics and you are
reasonably confident that they they have
been involved in some of these
activities some some names like Sarah
Smith that's come out recently there's
no surprise to me but not that way when
I heard his name for many many years so
died
and you're right I hadn't entirely
believed the stories or I thought but
whatever it was he done haven't been
very serious and have been exaggerated
so you are quite right it is possible to
be wrong about people but that it's
possible to be wrong about people
doesn't mean that this great national
conspiracy involving top people all over
the country transporting children to
secret locations I would need a lot of
convincing